Je ne sais pas pour vous, mais je n'ai pas encore vraiment compris
ce que la technologie signifie exactement dans ma vie.
J'ai passé l'année à réfléchir à propos de ce que cela devrait signifier.
Devrais-je être pro-technologie ? Devrais-je l'accueillir à bras ouverts ?
Devrais-je être prudent ? Comme vous, je suis très tenté par la dernière proposition.
Mais d'un autre côté, quelques années auparavant
j’ai renoncé à tous mes biens
vendu tous mes objets technologiques – sauf un vélo –
et j'ai parcouru environ 4800 kilomètres sur les petites routes des États-Unis par la seule force de mes muscles
nourris principalement par de la malbouffe.
(Rires)
Depuis, j’essaie de laisser la technologie
à distance de nombreuses manières, pour qu'elle ne maîtrise pas ma vie.
En même temps, je tiens un site internet sur des outils sympas
où j’expose mon obsession quotidienne pour les objets technologiques les plus récents
Donc je suis toujours perplexe à propos du véritable sens de la technologie
lors de sa relation à l’humanité, à la nature
ou au domaine spirituel.
Je ne suis même pas sûr que nous sachions ce qu'est la technologie.
Ce qui a été enregistré pour la première fois est une définition de la technologie.
C'est le premier exemple de l'usage moderne de la technologie que j'ai pu trouver.
C'était le programme proposé pour traiter des
arts appliqués et des sciences à l'université de Cambridge en 1829.
Avant ça, évidemment, la technologie n'existait pas. Mais bien sûr que si.
J'aime une des définitions qu'a Alan Kay pour la technologie.
Il dit que la technologie, c’est ce qui a été inventé après votre naissance.
(Rires)
Donc ça résume beaucoup de ce dont nous sommes en train de parler.
En fait, Danny Hillis a actualisé ce propos.
Pour lui, la technologie, c’est ce qui ne fonctionne pas encore vraiment.
(Rires)
Ce qui correspond également, je pense, à notre idée actuelle.
Mais j'étais intéressé par une autre définition de la technologie.
Par une définition qui, à nouveau, revenait à quelque chose de plus fondamental.
Quelque chose de plus profond. Alors que je luttais pour comprendre ça,
je suis arrivé à un moyen de formuler la question
qui semblait marcher pour moi dans mes enquêtes.
Et je vais aujourd'hui vous parler de ça pour la première fois.
Voici donc une tentative très grossière de réfléchir à voix haute.
La question à laquelle j'étais arrivé était la suivante
Qu'est-ce que veut la technologie ? Et par ça, je ne veux pas dire :
Est-ce qu'elle veut du chocolat ou de la vanille. Par ce qu'elle veut, je veux dire :
Quelles sont ses tendances et ses penchants inhérents ?
Quelles sont ses orientations au cours du temps ? Une façon de voir les choses est de
penser aux organismes biologiques, dont nous avons beaucoup entendu parler.
Richard Dawkins a une astuce, qui est de dire
de les regarder simplement comme des gènes, comme des véhicules pour gènes.
Et il dit : « Qu'est-ce que veulent les gènes ? » Le gène égoïste.
Et je suis en train d'utiliser une astuce similaire pour dire
« Et si nous regardions l'univers et notre culture
à travers les yeux de la technologie ? Qu'est-ce que veut la technologie ?
Évidemment, c'est une question incomplète,
de la même manière que d'observer un organisme comme un simple gène
est une manière incomplète de l'observer.
Mais c'est quand même très, très productif. Je suis donc en train d'essayer de dire
que si nous prenons le point de vue de la technologie sur notre monde, qu'est-ce qu'elle veut ?
Et je pense que lorsque nous avons posé la question
nous avons en fait à revenir à la vie. Parce qu'évidemment,
si nous ne cessons de repousser les origines de la technologie,
je pense qu'à un moment, nous revenons à la vie.
C'est donc ici que je souhaite débuter ma petite exploration, c'est dans la vie.
Et comme vous l'avez entendu grâce aux intervenants précédents,
nous ne savons pas vraiment quelle vie il y a sur Terre actuellement.
Nous n'avons vraiment aucune idée.
Le formidable et brillant effort de Craig Venter
pour séquencer l'ADN de choses dans l'océan est merveilleux.
Le travail de Brian Farrell fait entièrement partie de cette entreprise d'essayer
et de véritablement découvrir toutes les espèces sur Terre.
Et l'une des choses que nous devrions faire serait de simplement mailler la planète
et d'aller inspecter aléatoirement tous les endroits où les mailles se croisent,
simplement pour voir ce qu'il y a à apprendre sur la vie. Ei si nous faisions ça,
avec notre petite sonde martienne, ce que nous n'avons pas fait sur Terre,
nous pourrions commencer à voir des espèces incroyables.
Ce n'est pas sur une autre planète. Ces choses
sont cachées sur notre planète.
C'est une fourmi qui emmagasine le miel de ses collègues dans son abdomen.
Chacun de ces organismes que nous avons décrits – que vous avez vus –
grâce à Jamie et d'autres, ces choses magnifiques –
ce qu'elles font, chacune d'entre elles,
c'est qu'elles violent les lois de la vie.
Je ne peux pas trouver un seul principe général de biologie
qui ne connaisse pas une exception quelque part par un quelconque organisme.
Chaque chose à laquelle nous pouvons penser –
et si vous avez entendu le discours d'Olivia à propos des habitudes sexuelles,
vous réaliserez qu'il n'y a rien dont nous pouvons dire que c'est vrai pour toute vie.
Parce que chacune d'elles en viole une partie.
Ceci est une limace de mer nourrie grâce au soleil. C'est une nudibranche
qui a incorporé du chloroplaste pour produire son énergie.
Ceci en est une autre version. C'est un dragon de mer,
et celui du dessous, le bleu, est un jeune qui n'a pas encore
avalé l’acide, pas encore fait entrer
l’algue marron-vert dans son corps pour lui donner de l’énergie.
Ce sont des violations, et si nous regardons la forme générale
des approches de violation de la vie, il y a, selon le consensus actuel,
six règnes. Six grandes approches différentes : les plantes,
les animaux, les champignons, les protistes, les petites choses – les bactéries
et les archées.
Ce sont les approches générales de la vie. C'est une façon de voir la vie sur Terre aujourd'hui.
Mais une façon plus intéressante,
la manière de la considérer sur le long terme
est de l'observer dans une perspective d'évolution.
Et ici nous avons une vue de l'évolution où plutôt que de l'observer
se passer de manière linéaire, nous l'avons provenant du centre.
Au centre se trouve donc la période la plus lointaine, et c'est un diagramme généalogique
de toute la vie sur Terre. C'est exactement la même chose que les six règnes, vous voyez.
Quatre mille espèces représentées, et vous pouvez voir où nous sommes.
Mais ce que j'aime dans ce diagramme, c'est qu'il montre que
tous les organismes vivant sur Terre aujourd'hui ont autant évolué les uns que les autres.
Ces champignons et ces bactéries sont extrêment évolués comme les humains.
Ils existent depuis aussi longtemps et ont traversé
exactement les mêmes épreuves et difficultés pour être ici.
Mais nous pouvons voir que chacun d'entre eux en réalité viole les règles,
et a une manière différente de trouver comment vivre.
Et si nous regardons les tendances à long terme de la vie, si nous commençons à dire :
« Qu'est-ce que veut l'évolution ? », il y a plusieurs choses dont nous nous apercevons.
L'une d'entre elles est qu'il n'y a nul endroit sur Terre
où nous ayons été où nous n'avons trouvé aucune vie.
Nous trouvons de la vie au fond de chaque
carottage à long terme, à longue distance
que nous ramenons, et il y a des bactéries dans les pores de cette roche.
Et partout où se trouve la vie, elle ne se retire jamais. Elle est omniprésente et elle veut l'être encore plus.
De plus en plus de la matière inerte du globe
est touchée et animée par la vie.
La deuxième chose que nous voyons est la diversité. Nous observons aussi la spécialisation.
Nous voyons l'évolution depuis une cellule souche
jusqu'à ce qu'elle devienne plus spécifique et spécialisée.
Et nous observons une évolution vers la complexité qui est très intuitive.
Et en fait, nous avons des données actuelles qui nous montrent
qu'il y a une véritable évolution vers la complexité au fil du temps.
Et la dernière chose sur laquelle je reviens : cette nudibranche.
L'une des choses que nous observons à propos de la vie, c'est qu'elle évolue
de l'intérieur pour améliorer sa sociabilité. Cela veut dire
qu'il y a de plus en plus de vie dont l'environnement entier est constitué d'autres formes de vie.
Comme ces cellules chloroplastes,
qui sont totalement entourées d'autres formes de vie.
Elles ne touchent jamais la matière intérieure. Il y a de plus en plus de co-évolution.
Ainsi, les tendances générales, à long terme de l'évolution
sont approximativement les cinq suivantes : l'omniprésence, la diversité, la spécialisation,
la complexité et la socialisation. Maintenant, je garde ça, et je dis :
« D'accord, quelles sont les tendances à long terme de la technologie ? »
Et à nouveau, ma question est : « Qu'est-ce que veut la technologie ? »
Et ainsi, j'ai découvert remarquablement
qu'il y a aussi une évolution vers la spécialisation.
Que nous voyons qu'il y a un marteau générique,
et les marteaux deviennent de plus en plus spécifiques au cours du temps.
Il y a évidemment de la diversité. Une quantité énorme d'objets.
Ceci est le contenu entier d'une maison japonaise.
En fait, j'avais… J'ai donné un compteur à ma fille
et je lui ai donné la mission l'été dernier de partir
compter le nombre d'espèces technologiques dans notre ménage.
Elle est revenue avec six mille différents types de produits.
J'ai fait quelques recherches et j'ai découvert que le Roi d'Angleterre, Henry VIII,
avait seulement environ sept mille objets dans son ménage.
Et il était Roi d'Angleterre,
et c'était la fortune entière de l'Angleterre à cette époque.
Nous voyons ainsi énormément de diversité dans ce genre de choses.
Voici une scène de Star Wars où Z-6PO sort
et voit des machines fabriquer des machines. Quelle perversion !
Eh bien, c'est en fait ce vers quoi nous nous dirigeons : un monde de machines.
Et la technologie est supplantée seulement par d’autres technologies.
La plupart des machines ne seront en contact qu'avec d'autres technologies
et rien d'autre, pas même la vie.
Et troisièmement, l'idée que les machines sont en train de devenir biologiques et complexes
est à ce point un cliché. Et je suis heureux de dire
que j'étais en partie responsable de ce cliché
comme quoi les machines deviennent biologiques, mais c'est assez évident.
Les tendances majeures en technologie sont donc en fait
les mêmes que dans l'évolution biologique. Les mêmes tendances que nous observons
vers l'omniprésence, vers la diversité, vers la sociabilité,
vers la complexité. Ce n'est peut-être pas une grande surprise
parce que si nous traçons, disons, l'évolution des armures,
vous pouvez en fait suivre une sorte d'arbre ramifié des types d'évolution.
Je suggère, en fait, que la technologie est le septième règne du vivant.
Que ses opérations et la façon dont elle fonctionne sont si proches
que nous pouvons penser qu'il s'agit du septième règne.
Et ce serait un peu approximatif ici,
sorti du règne animal. Et si nous avions à faire cela,
nous trouverions – nous pourrions en fait aborder la technologie dans ce sens.
C'est Niles Eldredge. Il était le co-développeur avec Stephen Jay Gould
de la théorie de l'équilibre ponctué.
Mais à côté de ça, il lui arrive de collectionner les cornets.
Il a l'une des collections les plus grandes du monde, d'environ cinq cents cornets.
Et il a décidé de les considérer comme des trilobites ou des escargots,
et de faire une analyse morphologique,
et d'essayer de trouver les sources de leur histoire généalogique au cours du temps.
C'est son diagramme, qui n'a pas encore publié.
Mais l'aspect le plus intéressant à propos de ça,
c'est que si vous regardez ces lignes rouges au fond,
elles indiquent, au fond, la naissance d'un type de cornets
qui n'a plus été fabriqué. Cela n'arrive pas en biologie.
Quand quelque chose est éteint, vous ne pouvez pas l'avoir comme parent.
Mais cela arrive dans la technologie. Et il s'avère
que c'est si spécial de pouvoir vraiment regarder cet arbre,
et vous pouvez en fait l'utiliser pour déterminer
qu'il y a un système technologique contre un système biologique.
En fait, cette idée de faire ressuciter l'idée entière est si importante
que j’ai commencé à réfléchir à ce qui se passe avec la vieille technologie.
Et il s'avère qu'en fait, la technologie ne meurt pas.
J'ai donc fait part de ça à un historien des sciences, et il a dit
« Bien, qu'en est-il alors, vous savez, qu'en est-il des voitures à vapeur ?
Il n'y en a plus. » Eh bien en fait, si.
En vérité, il y en a tant autour de nous que vous pouvez acheter des nouvelles pièces pour une automobile à vapeur Stanley.
Et il y a un site itnernet d'un type qui vend des nouvelles pièces
pour cette automobile Stanley. Et ce que j'aime bien,
c'est ce genre de bouton « cliquez pour ajouter à votre panier » –
(Rires)
pour acheter des soupapes à vapeur. Je veux dire, c'était juste – Ça existe vraiment.
Donc, j'ai commencé à penser que peut-être ce n'était qu'un exemple au hasard.
Peut-être que je devrais faire ce classement d'une manière plus traditionnelle.
J'ai donc pris le grand et merveilleux catalogue de Montgomery Ward de 1895
et je l'ai parcouru au hasard. J'ai pris une page – pas tout à fait une page au hasard –
j'ai pris une page qui était vraiment plus difficile que les autres
parce que beaucoup de pages sont remplies d’objets
qui sont encore fabriqués. Mais j'ai pris cette page
et je me suis demandé : « Combien de ces objets sont encore fabriqués ? »
Et pas des antiquités. Je veux savoir combien de ces objets sont encore en production.
Et la réponse est : tous.
Tous sont encore en train d'être produits. Vous avez ainsi des égreneuses de maïs.
Je ne sais pas qui a besoin d'une égreneuse de maïs.
Que ce soit des égreneuses de maïs – vous avez des charrues, vous avez des moulins à vent
tous ces objets, qui ne sont pas, je le répète, des antiquités. Ils sont –
vous pouvez les commander. Vous pouvez aller sur internet et vous pouvez les acheter maintenant,
flambant neufs. Donc d'une certaine façon, les technologies ne meurent pas.
En fait, vous pouvez acheter, pour cinquante dollars, un couteau de l'âge de pierre
fait exactement de la même manière qu'il était fabriqué dix mille ans auparavant.
Ce court manche en os, cinquante dollars. Et en fait,
ce qui est important, c'est que cette information n'est jamais réellement morte.
Ce n'est pas seulement qu'elle a été ressucitée. Elle a toujours continué d'exister.
Et en Papouasie Nouvelle Guinée, ils faisaient des haches de pierre
jusqu'il y a vingt ans auparavant, simplement pour des questions pratiques.
Même quand nous essayons de nous débarrasser d'une technologie, c'est en fait très difficile.
Donc nous avons tous entendu parler des Amish abandonnant les voitures.
Nous avons entendu parler des japonais abandonnant les armes à feu.
Nous avons entendu parler de ci et de ça. Mais je suis revenu en arrière et
j'ai pris ce que j'ai pu trouver, les exemples de l'histoire
où il y a eu des interdictions contre les technologies,
et j'ai essayé de déterminer quand elles étaient – quand l'interdiction a été supprimée,
parce que les technologies reviennent toujours. Et il s'avère que le temps,
la durée pendant laquelle elles étaient hors-la-loi et interdites,
diminue au cours du temps. Et qu'au fond, vous pouvez retarder une technologie,
mais vous ne pouvez pas la tuer. Donc c'est cohérent. Parce que dans un certain sens,
ce qu'est la culture, c'est une accumulation d'idées.
C'est sa raison d'être. À tel point que les idées ne disparaissent pas.
Et quand nous saisissons ça, nous comprenons cette idée de ce que la culture est en train de faire
et nous l'ajoutons à la trajectoire à long terme – à nouveau, dans l'évolution de la vie –
nous trouvons que chaque cas – chacune des transitions majeures dans la vie –
ce qu'ils sont exactement, c'est une accélération et un changement
de la façon dont l'évolution se passe.
Elles sont en fait en train de changer la manière dont les idées naissent.
Donc toutes ces étapes de l'évolution améliorent, au fond,
l'évolution de l'évolubilité.
Ce qui se passe donc au cours du temps, c'est
que les façons de faire naître de nouvelles idées, de nouvelles violations
augmentent. Et les vraies astuces sont les manières,
en quelque sorte, d'explorer la façon d'explorer.
Et ainsi, ce que nous voyons dans la singularité,
qui a été prophétisée par Kurzweil et d'autres,
son idée que la technologie accélère l'évolution.
Ça accélère la manière dont nous recherchons des idées.
Donc si vous avez des violations de la vie –
la vie signifie des violations, le jeu de la survie –
alors l'évolution est une façon d'étendre le jeu en changeant les règles.
Et le résultat de la technologie, ce sont de meilleures manières d'évoluer.
C'est ce que nous appelons un jeu infini.
C'est la définition d'un jeu infini. Un jeu fini est le fait de jouer pour gagner,
et un jeu infini est joué pour continuer à jouer.
Et je pense que la technologie est en fait une force cosmique.
Les origines de la technologie ne sont pas en 1829,
mais c'était en fait au début du Big Bang,
et à ce moment, la totalité des milliards d'étoiles de l'univers
étaient compressées. L'univers entier était compressé dans une petite boîte quantique,
et c'était si serré là dedans qu'il n'y avait aucune place pour de la différence.
C'est la définition. Il n'y avait aucune température.
Il n'y avait aucune différence, quelle qu'elle fût. Et durant le Big Bang,
ce qui s'étendit fut le potentiel pour de la différence.
Ainsi, alors qu'il s'étend et que les choses s'étendent, ce que nous avons,
c'est le potentiel pour des différences, de la diversité, des options, des choix,
des opportunités, des possibilités et des libertés.
Ce sont fondamentalement les mêmes choses.
Et c'est ce que la technologie nous amène.
C'est ce que la technologie nous amène : des choix, des possibilités, des libertés.
Voilà de quoi il s'agit. C'est cet agrandissement de la place pour créer des différences.
Ainsi, un marteau, lorsque nous prenons un marteau, c'est ce que nous attrapons.
Et c'est pourquoi nous continuons de nous emparer de la technologie,
parce que nous voulons ces objets. Ils sont bons.
Les différences, les libertés, les choix, les possibilités.
Et chaque fois que nous faisons une place libre aux opportunités,
nous autorisons une plate-forme à en créer de nouvelles.
Et je pense que c'est vraiment important. Parce que si vous pouvez imaginer
Mozart avant que la technologie du piano soit inventée,
quelle perte pour la société cela aurait été.
Imaginez que Van Gogh soit né
avant les technologies de peintures bon marché.
Imaginez Hitchcock avant les technologies du cinéma.
Quelque part, aujourd'hui, il y a des millions de jeunes enfants en train de naître
dont les technologies d'expression personnelle n'ont pas été inventées.
Nous avons une obligation morale d'inventer des technologies
pour que chaque personne sur la planète ait le potentiel
de se rendre compte de sa vraie différence.
Nous voulons un milliard de tas d'espèces d'un individu.
C'est ce que la technologie veut vraiment.
Je vais passer sur quelques objections
parce que je n'ai pas de réponses à la raison de la déforestation
je n'ai pas de réponse sur le fait qu'il y ait – qu'il semble y avoir –
de mauvaises technologies. Je n'ai pas de réponse sur
la manière dont ceci influe sur notre dignité, autrement que de proposer que
peut-être les sept règnes – parce que c'est si proche de la raison de la vie –
peut-être pouvons-nous les ramener et nous en servir pour surveiller la vie.
Peut-être que d'une certaine manière,
ce que nous essayons de faire avec la technologie, c'est de lui trouver sa place.
C'est une chose terrible de vaporiser du DDT sur des champs de coton,
mais c'est vraiment une bonne chose de l'utiliser
pour éliminer des millions de morts à cause de la malaria dans un petit village.
Notre humanité est véritablement déterminée par la technologie.
Toutes les choses que nous pensons vraiment aimer à propos de l'humanité
sont amenées par la technologie. C'est le jeu infini.
C'est ce dont nous parlons.
Vous voyez, la technologie est un moyen de faire évoluer l'évolution.
C'est un moyen d'explorer des possibilités et des opportunités et d'en créer davantage.
Et c'est en fait une manière de jouer le jeu, de jouer à tous les jeux.
C'est ce que veut la technologie.
Donc quand je réfléchis à ce que veut la technologie,
je pense que cela a un rapport avec le fait que chaque personne ici – et je crois vraiment à ça –
chaque personne ici a une mission. Et votre mission est
de passer votre vie à découvrir ce qu'est votre mission.
Cette nature récursive est le jeu infini.
Et si vous y jouez correctement, d'autres personnes y prendront part
donc même ce jeu s'agrandit et continue même lorsque vous êtes parti.
C'est le jeu infini. Et ce qu'est la technologie,
c'est le moyen grâce auquel nous jouons à ce jeu infini.
Donc je pense que nous devrions adopter la technologie
parce que c'est une partie essentielle de notre parcours
pour découvrir qui nous sommes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)